[Music]
in faking the funk news submitted by
b-rabbit from ninth model or a amount
you get what I'm saying a man is being
accused of spending 4.1 million dollars
on a company credit card to fund his
music career oh and he still didn't make
it took that money and just bought 4
point 1 million copies of your single
they never think of that [ __ ] why you go
that far out of the way you could get at
number 1 on iTunes if you bought you all
like on the same day yeah oh yes easy
then he's gonna be trending now people
are actually going to check you out
yeah now you gotta go to jail dig here
yep so just see if you get better sound
equipment or whatever you think this guy
his name is Chad Arrington ciao
aka Chad focus what kind of music was he
doing so he did have a minor hit last
year called dance with me and it did
land him on the top billboard dance song
song start no [ __ ] so he was like north
30-something wow that's pretty good yeah
cuz he did when he bought it he bought
[ __ ] wops fix what I like part of the
purchases were having bought fake likes
and fake followers and he also used that
money to have this gigantic billboard in
Times Square that's 5 grand
yeah they're not that much sad focus oh
Lord and this is the billboard oh that's
a big boy nevermind that's at that spot
expensive so this is like his artist
[ __ ] and then his real life handled for
this whole time I thought he was like a
like a EDM like dance kind of guy yeah
so under this one is Chad focus it says
number-one artist in the world
so Beyonce you gotta sell your [ __ ] man
that's like number one sandwich shop
world's best [ __ ] that's it so you
say that [ __ ] all over so you're right
you know I found someone who falls for
that [ __ ] my stepdad
every time he keith travels he comes
back he goes you know what gives us the
number-one [ __ ] cookie of the
philippines he's yeah and he's like
guess what it was right by my hotel
that's the perfect location when he goes
in with will ferrell he goes in because
it says like world's best coffees i
could graduate he will be doing about
ridiculous [ __ ] my followers is probably
the lamest [ __ ] that you could do ya
know all the obvious reasons but because
it serves no purpose that they're not
organic followers they're not gonna see
it on a fee and then that go support you
it's just a legal inflation that's like
the chick with like 5 million Instagram
followers and she sold 3rd she couldn't
even sell 30 t-shirt oh how do you even
how unbelievable that doesn't even sound
real cuz you bought that [ __ ] it's so
ridiculous yes so he also purchased fake
streams for his songs that's crazy that
you could do that [ __ ] big song leave
shots and that's it that you can do it
and I think it was but I mean not behind
Jake oh wait you can do what exactly by
fake streams career music so make sure
stream counts yeah kind of like like
views on videos got it
you could buy fake YouTube views but
then they'll catch it and then close the
account and that's the same thing with
Instagram like if they see that like you
know they do that purge every year when
I go through those accounts and all the
bots and all the fake accounts they
delete them people be losing ten to
fifteen thousand followers because
they're companies that open up a bunch
of accounts and then they set them up
with BOTS and then they have them go
from different IP of the world and then
they look at the video so then it goes
up in the video count in India they have
hold like huge like almost like
factories filled with computer parts and
I'm just like toss them yeah watching
views and refreshing video yeah refresh
videos boosting the count mister he also
used the company's money to invest in a
bike share company how do you show bike
the tandem bicycles I mean it's like
those whether you just ride it and just
drop off and somebody they hit us up for
a brand deal oh well I don't know if
this is the actual company but it's like
a Airbnb for bike I mean yeah
for bikes it's like people have their
own bicycles and then you could like
rent ten bucks a day and then they have
all kinds of bicycle like mountain bikes
they got like that old school bike with
the big-ass [ __ ] wheel in a little
wheel in the back that's from like
normal everyday people though it's not
from a company
sounds like Toro for bikes yes yes yes
yeah turtle yeah that's the apples thing
about alright get on that bike that's
weird as [ __ ] like it's just a bike it
doesn't matter a little I guess it'll
bike it's not gonna go for you unless
it's like I'm I'm holder eyes a couple
years ago I got that bike in a sketch
the one that's a big-ass wheel in the
front wheel on the front you get on it
with a ladder or just stuff like do you
get off you gotta wait you gotta go back
to the ladder you gotta help them down
do it a few years they mean when I was
producing they made me get [ __ ]
unicycle that they never learn we still
have them we try it was really high
right we had this imagined nation of
like doing drive-bys with unicycles
video right and in in our heads this
[ __ ] played out so easy like oh man
we'll learn it we'll just [ __ ] roll
it in if I can do this we never learned
how to do it well hardware oh man
that's funny I don't think I've ever
seen anybody do that before I would ever
know what ideas he's not finding out
somebody's done it before I was so
[ __ ] mad like I wanted to shoot a
sketch when we driving a car but like
the walking cane outside the car like
the black I know this is gonna be
[ __ ] phenomenal and I found out they
had did this is some old movie I thought
I was onto something
yeah but that I've never heard of
that'll be funny yeah well somebody's
gonna steal enough so now it's too hard
bottom and Bailey that do it other than
that guy [ __ ] on our block this like
70 year old man he just like rolled up
on a unicycle like rode back past our
house we were like okay he just waves
and then you guys what he's [ __ ] with
you
no that's how you know we live in a safe
neighborhood I just seven-year-old
grandpa's on unicycles yes a foreign
[ __ ] Narnia yeah somebody walls up on
my house and waves at me from your
unicycle I took it as a warning okay he
does later let's make sure we both his
now is empty that is strange
I'd be like my neighbor's a part of the
circus that's a positive spin on it yeah
so anyway Ted focus here he also bought
this other billboard that was closer to
his home chat was a a lien doing there
focusing his musics out-of-this-world I
will teach you how to be famous world's
best marketer also marketing instructor
Elian it should be like universe is miss
yeah marketer you need help he needs
help what does he do I'm not surprised
he got caught I don't get the alien part
how do you spend 4.5 million dollars on
buying likes and one dope on a billboard
they didn't admit to all the clothes and
stuff that he probably bought to I'm
sure there's an image that he probably
kept like the car the the chains love I
miss all those buy sites there's like a
couple hundred bucks or something that's
not like [ __ ] that was what company
did he work for
oh it's insane how they just never went
hey who bought like ten bottles of
Cristal
he was an SEO specialist search engine
optimizations nerd bod a rapper by night
he faces a maximum of 20 years in prison
for federal charges of conspiracy wire
fraud and aggravated identity theft
identity
what's larceny tips stealing because
it's just sounds so I feel like we
Google a bit yeah and none of us still
understood what it meant stealing theft
of personal property why don't they just
call it theft yeah I don't know that's
my grand larceny update - yeah what's
the difference between grand theft grand
larceny so they're saying that in most
jurisdictions there's no difference
between larceny and theft
this is the difference in words you're
right I mean it just depends if your
judge still wears like a Raj Washington
wig or not so I think robbery is larceny
with the use of threat of force burglary
is entering the property of another with
the intent to commit a crime there
within there in there in I'm so glad
they make theoretically that that makes
it easy yeah I know why do they write
laws like it's the Old Testament of the
Bible which is because they still need
lawyers to be able to translate
everything for us basically sound alike
King James English and [ __ ] right any
time I read any legal document like I
just got sent something because I'm
signing with the thing and I was reading
it and I was like how the [ __ ] do you do
this without a lawyer you can't
LegalZoom
Oh giggles oh man there's an
the one we can like draw up contracts
ooh that I've used before I can't think
of it right now but yeah they should
simplify this [ __ ] just like how taxes
is so great why they make it complicated
they're hoping that big catch you
slippin we're trying to keep lawyers in
business man 20 years and he still
didn't make it though like to be able to
burn 4.5 millions on up crazy life and
in for the rest 20 years just like
chillin you're like that was a dope life
no I'm trying to escape somehow escape
to a third-world country the four
million dollar would you rather have
that or have a boring life and then you
die I wanna boring my life and keep my
BA home intact yeah yeah you can still
see some good movies in the Borah life
but isn't he going to like a nice prison
because it was just white collar crime I
mean but it's still prison you don't
think they have but sex and white-collar
crimes
yeah but it's all consensual I heard no
it's not they just said the invite hey
I'm coming over it's not really like hey
do you want me to coming over when that
guy did that in front of you in the yard
or whatever uh did the other guy look
worried or sad about it yeah that's what
these hey so let me holla Joey and then
I was talking about work he needs a turn
and he was like I gotta go I think it's
the context it's a new video so they
don't know all right yeah right so he
was he was talking to he was working in
a prison and a gentleman that he was
talking to a prisoner he actually got to
talk to a prisoner who was like
proposition for sex and I apparently
it's not that consensual really also let
me say it was a jail not a prison just
for the people that been out there and
they know the difference and you know I
don't think was more of a proposition as
like hey it's time for that one thing do
we do whether you want to not do it like
all right you're teaching classes yeah
but I was going through at this point
you collected paper because sometimes
when they get in trouble they'll shut
those classes down and I'll still go
through a collect work so they can still
because you get the homework from all
the inmates yeah and give me I saw it go
down well I mean you know I didn't see
that go down oh but you saw like hey
it's time for some licking it's so
sticky that alone should make people not
want to go to jail just thinking about
getting that just taken it just makes
the car ride home
unbearable maybe just maybe that guy
takes him back there and then he sticks
it in the other guy so he makes it look
him me
there's always an option it's time for
you to butt-fuck me it's possible that
be his lucky day
wouldn't that be nice maybe he's like
our again I've so chafed we are built
[Music]
[Music]